in the dead of night musa muhammad used
the cover of scaffolding to gain access
to the roof of the embassy of bahrain
once there he unfurls his banner I'm
risking my life to save two men about to
be executed in the next few hours
it reads we did many protests we do send
them letters for the human rights
organization and there you and as well
it doesn't stop but I feel in my in my
heart there's something I can't do to
save their life that's why I went to the
rooftop of behind the embassy shortly
afterwards the police arrived and for a
good ten minutes nothing much happens as
they try to work out how to handle the
situation on the roof mr. Mohammed
appears relaxed sibling from a water
bottle occasionally calling on the
British prime minister to call the King
of Bahrain to urge the country to
respect human rights
[Music]
but suddenly everything changes a figure
appears on the roof next to the
protestor the police response is
dramatic look at it again it's at this
point that mr. Mohammed says he was
beaten with a stick and almost forced
off the roof mr. Mohammed can be seen
being pulled from the ledge to the
ground during this time he says to his
threatens were being beaten to death we
want to throw your from here as a sheep
and no one is gonna help you here even
the UK police the first nun they said
even the fax was done and the second
time they said even the bullet UK police
they can't they can't help you no one's
come can come to us here in our land and
after so you were quite clear that you
thought that they were going to beat you
to death inside the embassy yes I
it was a clear and they say this as well
certainly his friends filming at all
from the ground are terrified urging the
police to do something officers forced
to push them back within a minute or two
the fire services forced the doors of
the embassy and officers go in some
numbers the embassy has said it regards
mr. Muhammad's protest as being in
support of what it describes as
terrorists and in the end what happened
on the roof is their word against his
but what was extraordinary was the
police response because officers plainly
were so concerned about mr. Muhammad's
safety that they had no compunction in
breaking every rule in the diplomatic
handbook and ordering the forcing of the
doors of the embassy of another country
mr. Mohammed says when the embassy staff
realized the police were in the building
their attitude changed entirely the
third man who told them fourth man the
police break in the door
and that before that before not and
that's when they stopped attacking you
is it yes exactly so he told them don't
beat him as for the two men mr. Mohammed
was protesting for their executions went
ahead as planned amid allegations that
they'd been tortured in jail
in London an indication of how concerned
the police are about what might happen
to protesters inside the walls of the
embassies of Gulf states
Lawrence Lee al-jazeera London